if you're looking for a guy or a woman a
person that i could identify right now
on the national political landscape who
can handle china who can handle russia
who can handle all the issues who who
doesn't need to be brought up to speed
who's smart tulsi gabbard do you think
oh god no no oh my god no no god that's
right she is
listen
that
that woman should not be allowed to wear
a uniform oh whoa
whoa okay she explains
then you understand you don't do
politics in uniform she's going on
social media and her colonel's uniform
and doing politics
that's a big no no i'm talking about
everyone's done it
i will never she she no when you go and
you meet with that that man dropped
barrel bombs on children she dropped
barrel bombs on children they dropped
chlorine gas on kids no no no no no no
she does not get in a pass
she's the only american official in
seven years who stood with that son of a
[ __ ]
if you want to have talk about values
right do we stand for something you
don't go and stand next to assad and he
said he's a good man trying to do right
would you would you would you agree to
do a sit down with uh tulsi and you only
if i could spit in her face
wow i can't stand her i think she is
well that that's just not gonna work i
think i think she is i think she is a
complete
and and total disappointment she is she
is
derelict in her duty she is engaged in
conduct on becoming behavior she ought
to be court-martialed for what she's
done in uniform
it's unfortunate you feel that way about
somebody conduct aren't becoming she got
into a uniform and witnessed so let me
ask you a different question let me ask
you a different question the easiest
charge to bring up by the way as a
commander if i was her commander i'd
bring her up on conduct unbecoming well
becoming well
maybe that's what we talk about next
time
we put a glass in between you guys
and and uh do you really know chelsea of
course if you can get me into chelsea i
will not spit on her but you got to be
respectful bro i would be respectful
with her but she needs because she by
the way here's one thing about tulsi
she's going to see this and she's going
to say something if she responds
she is she is not going to say if you
want to have an opinion take off your
uniform i'm serious if you see this i
don't know what camera am i looking at
take off your uniform i'm saying this to
you as one fellow officer or another i'm
not sitting here doing this in uniform
right now right take off your uniform if
you want to continue to have an opinion
you swore an oath like the rest of us
how dare you that's why and by the way
apologize for meeting assad you met with
a war criminal it's like standing next
to hitler and being proud of it you seen
tulsi in a bikini she looks pretty good
when she takes off her uniform listen
tulsi is somebody that makes a lot of
sense and has a lot of loyal followers
so it's going to be interesting to see
what happens there so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you